the date for the next European election
has been set from the 6th to the 9th of
June 2024 every person in every member
state will go to vote
European Union democracy is more
important today than ever your vote
matters it will decide the direction our
Union will take it will decide what
Europe you want to see
over the past years we have experienced
a global pandemic war on our continent
an energy crisis inflation and cyber
warfare all while the clock of a climate
emergency keeps on ticking the European
Union has delivered our response has
been unprecedented we have come together
in defense of our values and for our way
of life we have done this in solidarity
we have been firm in our support of
Ukraine we have procured vaccines for
All European Union citizens because we
have realized that we get more when we
are together
today EU citizens are more protected in
the event of an emergency or a disaster
we have seen Romanian firefighters in
Spain
French patients treated in Luxembourg
hospitals Slovenian rescue workers
helping Italy Estonian cyber Tech
providing security for us all that is
solidarity that is Europe a Europe we
cannot take for granted and we are
working for more fairness between people
with new rules for equal pay our new
European migration laws will mean a
process that is fair with those in need
of protection firm with those who are
not eligible and strong against
traffickers exploiting the most
vulnerable
our new European climate laws will mean
cleaner air healthier rivers and seas
stronger economies they will bring about
the green transition and make us the
first carbon neutral continent by 2050.
together with the digital transition it
will bring new opportunities increase
our competitiveness and bring economic
growth
the European Union is not perfect it is
evolving continuously the world is
changing and we must change with it also
we need reform we cannot be afraid of
change we must embrace it as we keep
listening keep explaining and keep
delivering for that Europe needs you to
take part
to not give in to easy cynicism and
indifference to recapture the sense of
hope and possibility that the European
Union offers to vote
don't miss out on the next European
elections get on the register be part of
the largest Democratic exercise in
Europe
do not let someone else choose for you
vote